hey everyone it's Mike from water flows
and I wanna tell you about an upcoming
webinar that I'm doing on Thursday
August 23rd 2018 I'll be talking about
using order flow to find price rejection
and most importantly how to profit from
that price rejection now I'll be
speaking on the investor inspiration
make your money work for you workshop
it's a live Q&A webinar to help you know
help traders get exposed to different
forms of market analysis and it's quite
a nice lineup this time we got James
Edwards you got Aaron Hunsaker Fausto
myself Vince and Lawrence Macmillan now
if your ever studied options and you
know you've gone to the library got to
the bookstore looking for an options
book it's probably one of them is
written by Lawrence Macmillan and when I
was just getting started out in the
industry back in the early 90s and I was
on the trading floor somebody gave me a
book on options to send I read this so
you can understand options better and it
was Lawrence Macmillan on options and
actually I still refer to it today when
I got questions about some options
strategy I want to know a little bit
more about so what I will be talking
about in particular is price rejection
and price rejection occurs when traders
are rejecting high prices or low prices
and I'll just teach you how to profit
from it you know everyone likes to talk
about support and resistance and support
resistance is you know one of the basis
of trading you know that's what moves
the market markets move from support to
resistance and and back and forth but
you know something that people don't
really talk about very much is price
rejection and honestly price rejection
is hard to see in the markets and why is
price rejection important is because
it's gonna allow you to catch trends
when they begin you know imagine if you
knew when a move was ending based on
prices being rejected based on the
market's perception of prices being too
high or too low
that's what price rejection is it is is
when traders come to the collective
reasoning that you know the markets too
expensive they're not gonna buy anymore
or the markets too cheap they're not
gonna sell anymore and often that's
where the market turns and that's when
you get nice reversals and nice trends
and you can get in early you know like I
said you know everyone always says the
trend is your friend the trend is your
friend
but they only talk about trends after
they've begun and already started making
the moves what if you get in earlier you
know that's that's where the the real
meat and potatoes is on a trade now
honestly price rejection is not easy to
see if you're looking at a normal bar
chart it's gonna be quite difficult to
see because you know one of the ways you
couldn't tell the easy way to tell
prices are being rejected is by looking
at volume and I'm gonna show you how to
see it in order flow and I'll also show
you a way to see it on bar charts okay
so this is you know I think this is
going to be new information for a lot of
traders you know I said a lot of traders
never thought of price rejection which
actually runs contrary to support and
resistance in the in the sense of
support or resistance meaning you know a
lot of buyers or a lot of sellers are
coming into the market price rejection
is the opposite it's it's the lack of
buyers or the lack of sellers now just
you know a brief disclaimer just so you
know you know the presentation that I'm
doing on Thursday is for educational
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures train contain substantial risk
and is not for every investor and
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for training and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results so again you know the sign-up
link is in the description below just go
there it takes you to this page here
where you just enter your name your
email there's a spot for your phone
number I don't think you have to enter
it but most definitely your name an
email and that's important it's because
you know if you can't attend they will
probably post it up on YouTube in a
couple of weeks they don't go up there
immediately but if you can't attend and
you want to get access to my replay as
soon as it's ready I'll send it out to
you it usually takes within within 24
hours you'll get it so sign up and you
know I hope to see you there on Thursday
you know I think it's going to be a very
interesting day you know I know that
James is here from complete currency
trader is going to be talking about
or X with level 2 order flow and there's
also another speaker here was it
which one is also gonna be talking about
level 3 data and using that in your in
your analysis so it's going to be an
interesting day and of course Lawrence
you know myself but also of course
Lawrence Macmillan talking about the
current status of option oriented
indicators you know options are a great
tool for a lot of people but honestly a
lot of people are scared of options and
you know I think that it's going to be a
very useful session to watch as well so
thanks and I hope to see you there on
Thursday again the sign-up link is in
the description below bye bye